bienvenue ou est-ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui on est à berlin on est à
l'ifa regardez c'est écrit si iref haifa
on est à mais ce mais se sait le grand
hall d'exposition se déroule tous les
ans il faut et cette année on est là
pourquoi on est là pour découvrir pour
aller revoir pourra y redécouvrir ce que
fait t clt si elle m'a dit tiens
monsieur revient faire un tour notre
temps on va aller voir les nouveautés on
va y regarder ce qui se passe d'ailleurs
c'est vachement intéressant parce qu'il
ya plein de nouveautés à 360° sur de la
télé sur du réfrigérateur sont dans la
machine à laver sur de la climatisation
beaucoup d'innovations assigné tcl doit
donc se faire ça aujourd'hui j'espère
que ça vous intéressera surtout
n'hésitez surtout pas à me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire et
on va essayer de rentrer parce qu'il ya
une canne ya des liens soleil de fou et
jackie star mario leader
on est sur le stand de tcl regardé hier
vous avez le slogan c'est le nouveau
slogan alors je vous montre il est juste
là regardez inspired greatness et l'idée
c'est quoi c'est d'inspirer le meilleur
de la technologie d'avoir le meilleur de
la technologie que ce soit dans
différents univers parce qu'ici les
tesselles on va parler plus
d'écosystèmes on va avoir des
aspirateurs des téléviseurs des
réfrigérateurs avoir des machines à
laver ou avoir des climatiseurs voir
beaucoup de produits donc c'est ce qu'on
va venir faire aujourd'hui un tour
complet de leur stand et déjà il ya tout
qui est très cool pas si vous le savez
mais à la fin de l'année vous avez coupe
du monde de football et tcl à quatre
ambassadeurs de renom on à raphaël
varane fils fowden rodrigo et pédri avec
ça donc ça c'est bien vous êtes prêt on
y va pour un tour complet du stand de
tcl quasiment complet parce que
tellement de choses vous allez bras les
innovations sont là et ça c'est beau
et si on commence par un décret en ce
sens 36 pouces est énorme alors regardez
je me recule pour vous voyez vraiment
136 pouces c'est un vrai mur et il
s'appelle le cinéma walls et de la micro
mais nous on a pas moins d'un million de
led led haute au mi6 et dire que c'est
elle qui vont émettre directement leur
propre lumière on se parle pas de zone
ici vous n'avez pas une zone avec
plusieurs led chaque led by met
directement sa propre lumière ça vous
permet donc d'avoir un détail absolument
incroyable un des noirs parfait une
gamme de couleurs qui est absolument
dingue ici au les siens du r&b et on
monte au maximum à 4 minutes c'est
beaucoup il n'y a pas besoin pensez vous
de votre côté vous avez pas message
suivant dans la division hdr tcl eyed
peas your engine bref il ya plein de
techno derrière qui font de ce mur un
truc absolument dingue c'était celle
vous avez aussi des moniteurs nous on va
s'intéresser à celui là c'est un 34
poussé ces deux-là miled si vous êtes
d'humeur et vous voulez un truc qu'il
tartiner qui carbure là vous en tout cas
c'est dingue c'est à dire que vous avez
effectivement un 34 pouces incurvé déjà
c'est quand même relativement grand en
plus sur un taux de rafraîchissement de
165 m haies avec un temps de réponse de
une milliseconde autant vous dire vous y
allez tac vous shooter c'est direct ça
envoie directement la patate et ça c'est
vachement cool le format je trouve juste
hyper canon vous posé sur un bureau vous
poser devant vous avez qu à y aller et
on est parti c'est du ministre c'est
fluide c'est un actif qui s'assortira ça
en 2023 vous le voyez j'ai testé il ya
plein de produits différents différentes
familles de produits mais aussi derrière
eux mêmes technologies on va se parler
de la rsr la rsr c'est quoi ce permettra
d'avoir plus de détails une image plus
nette des bords plus clair et de la
réduction - vous avez aussi light peak
you lie piqthiu ça fait quoi c'est la
reconnaissance de sa venue reconnaître
votre image va détecter éléments de
l'image par éléments de l'image contenir
totalement optimisé afin que vous ayez
est la meilleure restitution possible il
ya meilleure qualité d'image aux
différentes technologies toutes basées
sur de l'intelligence artificielle haute
technologie intéressante au niveau du
son vous avez un suivi du son et
imaginez vous allez au téléviseur et
l'action passe de droite à gauche gauche
à droite et bien grâce au suivi du son
vous n'êtes plus en immersion vous avez
pas juste l'impression d'avoir du son
qui arrive en face à vous suivez
l'action directement avec le son c'est
plus immersif et vous avez également
l'aï sonic adaptation à dire que le son
va venir s'adapter à votre pièce on n'a
pas tous les mêmes pièces on n'a pas
tous une grande baie vitrée ou alors une
petite pièce avec un son plus étouffé sa
dépense chaque pièce est unique et aux
romains de télévision à venir s'adapter
automatiquement à l'acoustique de votre
pièce pour optimiser l'expérience et
vous ayez le meilleur qualité audio
possible vous avez aussi des
technologies logicielles on va boire un
peu l'airplay 2 vous avez leur ai dit
joe va améliorer la qualité de l'image
notamment en modifiant le nom de la sps
vous avez également un mode gaming avec
une optimisation logiciel que ce soit
pour du chrono de gaming ou si vous
venez brancher une console dessus le
fameux mode jeu avec un temps de
réaction qui sera plus rapide vous avez
également du gaming avec la caméra 3d
qui va vous reconnaître qui va
reconnaître votre visage vos mouvements
vous êtes pouvoir avoir des jeux
interactifs grâce à votre caméra 3d dans
votre main et l'aele boucher ça bref un
truc et ludique est sympa et qui en plus
de ça vous fait bouger voudrait
également pour par la technologie
innovation fabrication de dalles avec
ses ailes et tué ceux tissés le
fabricant de dalles ici par exemple vous
avez un écran de 8 0 1 pouces et on va
pouvoir me replier l'écran à
360° dans un sens ou dans l'autre aile
truc est vachement intéressant aussi
c'est qu'ils retirent un truc qui
s'appelle le polar either fait le polar
either vous avez sur vos smartphones qui
spi ça sert à quoi ça sert à orienter la
lumière orienté vraiment la direction de
la lumière l'aï s'ils l'ont retirée
pense que votre l'aide elle va émettre
la lumière par elle même est de donner
un sens donc pas besoin d'eux pour la
raideur et le bénéfice c'est quoi
derrière égale bénéfices et que vous
allez avoir de meilleures sensations
lorsque vous allez venir le plier dans
un sens et dans l'autre cas sera plus
fluide beaucoup plus pratique et puis
surtout vous allez avoir une meilleure
qualité d'image autre innovation ça se
passe ici alors c'est patent produit
fini parce que c'est pas ça qui nous
intéresse ce produit n'est pas fini ce
qui nous intéresse c'est la dalle parce
qu'elle vraie innovation niveau de la
dalle regardez c'est écrit ici vous avez
75 pouces lui qu'à 120 hertz à 6,4
masque c'est vraiment le 4 mars dernière
nous intéresser ici on se parle purement
d'une innovation au niveau de la dalle
et hook est dingue en soi c'est une
première mondiale d'avoir ici quatre
masques au lieu de 5 usuellement c'est
en fait un nouveau procédé fabrication
parce que moins on met le masque - en
nette perte ce qui forcément entre la
lumière est ce que vous vous allez voir
vous avez un élément supplémentaire on a
retiré un élément un masque en moins se
permet d'optimiser totalement la qualité
l'image on est ici sur un mini led
rétroéclairé c'est une technologie
a breveté et on vient améliorer une fois
de plus la qualité du mini l'aide on
voit ici qu'à de nombreuses innovations
on voit beaucoup de produits finis ici à
lille face dans le temps d'ôter ciel
mais ici on se parle d'innovation pur et
dur au niveau de la fabrication des
dalles que ce soit sur des écrans de
smartphones 8 pouces ou alors carrément
ici sur une dalle de 75 pouces en mini
l'aide pour moi je voudrais qu'on se
parle de techno qui sont sur des
produits déjà sortie déjà annoncée on va
se parler mini legs en fait la mini
lèvres c'est quoi c'est une led mais
beaucoup plus petit et comme vous avez
détails qui sont réduites et
miniaturisés vous allez avoir beaucoup
plus de détails une image beaucoup plus
net et ça va complètement optimiser la
qualité d'autres images on pousse ici
vous avez des télés avec des taux de
rafraîchissement de 144 hertz le nombre
de m c'est quoi c'est le nombre d'image
que vous avez par seconde plus vous en
avez et plus ça va être fluide donc
lançant 44 r t on repense au retour
gaming pas tant aux films aux séries
mais ogami vous allez voir une
expérience qui va être bien meilleur
plus d'image par seconde va être
beaucoup plus fluide alors on se parle
ici de mini l'aide et de quantum dots on
a donc une image beaucoup plus nette au
revoir une image lumineuse on va
également avoir des noirs profonds par
des images contrastées donc on a
vraiment un ensemble cohérent qui est
vachement bien que ce soit pour regarder
des films des séries qui soit pour jouer
autant vous dire que là vous avez ce
qu'il faut deux divisions achiou hdr
d'esplus 144 hertz drs je voulais 10 et
un taux de rafraîchissement variables
cela dépend du fait plus de votes
contenu serez pas tout le temps 144
hertz pense que vous allez regarder un
film ou série vous ne serez pas 144 est
pas besoin mais lorsque vous avez besoin
de 144 rt bien votre télé elle peut
développer et ça c'est bien on également
une faible émission de lumière bleue
donc pour un confort de jeu c'est top
est il faible réflexion les designs on
citerait canon avec des finitions que
son premium et des dalles très fine des
bords très faim toutes les techno qui
vont bien au niveau de l'audio dolby
atmos imac ce n ait max end j'ai du mal
avec ce mot à chaque fois ils sortent
difficilement de la bouche dts hd le
fameux 103 quine le suivi du son du
2.1.2 60 watts et vous avez tout une
expérience en google tv derrière avec
google assistant avec google duo mira
cast pour pc airplay 2 ça je voulais
également dit en kit du contrôle vocal
wifi six loups tous 5 points 2 4 prises
hdmi 2.1 de l'usb2 bref vous avez tout
ce qui va bien toutes les nouvelles
technologies sont intégrés directement
dans les nouvelles télés tcl hommage aux
réponses par delà ces 935 et le flagship
qui la télé haut de gamme de tcl on va
pouvoir trouver en différentes tailles
et qui devrait arriver jeudi vient de
vrai parce que c'est pas encore cas est
déjà sorti en chine en 98 pouces là vous
avez ce que tu es si elle fait mieux
dans des visions hdr 10 plus c'est une
télé qui est extrêmement polyvalente qui
a très bien transports notamment pour la
coupe du monde parce que vous avez de la
fluidité que ce serait une super
expérience également pour le cinéma les
faits le streaming s'en ressent doutera
mais également pour le mode jeu avec
beaucoup de fluidité et en 98 pouces
s'il arrive en europe il pourrait
potentiellement arriver en fin d'année
on adresse en version 4 cas eh bien vous
auriez le plus grand téléviseur une
lettre disponible ici en europe ça
serait quand même plutôt pas mal donc si
vous voulez un très grand écran 90 pouce
salarial quoi faire ces grands noms
seront quand même d'une dalle
extrêmement lubie 2010 avec un pic à
2008 un taux de rafraîchissement
variable 244 rc doivent division ique h
dernis plus toutes les techno dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure au niveau de
l'audio au niveau de l'écran vous avez
le package complet le full package on
est ici son flagship le plus haut de
gamme mais j'étais cl vous avez
également d'autres produits pour la
maison divers et variés on n'est pas que
sur l'image on n'est pas que sur du son
il ya aussi des barres de son mais on en
parlera probablement une prochaine fois
on va se parler ici notamment de
climatiseurs quand on a vu la chaleur
qu'on ait cet été c'est quand même
vachement bien on va se parler également
du réfrigérateur on va se parler
également de lave linge pratique comme
ça vous avez un ensemble de produits
cohérents pour la maison connectée et ça
aussi c'est bien c'est celle à une
expertise de daria tout ce qui va être
climatisation climatiseurs vous en avez
tous les côtés mais nous on va
s'intéresser à ce produit là là haut et
nouveautés et qui est vachement
intéressant parlons de la fraîche et une
sérieuse alors comment ça se passe je
connaissais tous l'histoire de la
climatisation on prend de l'air ont
refroidi et ont l'âge acte chez vous
donc si c'est le même principe c'est à
dire qu'on va venir prendre de l'air à
l'extérieur on va venir le filtrer de
différentes manières afin de relever
toutes les impuretés d'enlever la
pollution et de vous restituer un air de
qualité on vient ensuite passer l'air
extérieur à la température que vous
souhaitez à l'intérieur donc à la
température ambiante et on vient vous si
tu es donc on a un air propre sain à la
maison mais en plus de cela il a une
fonction qui est intelligente il ya un
capteur de co2 l'idée c'est quoi venir
mesurer le taux de co2 dans votre
intérieur et s'ils voient qu'il ya un
petit peu trop de co2 eh bien il va
venir récupérer de l'air extérieur pour
dire on emmenait davantage comme ça vous
avez toujours un air à l'intérieur qui
va être maximisée pas de co2 tout cas
pas trop de co2 forcément il en faut
toujours un petit peu mais quand même
pas trop de co2 1ère purifier un air
respirable sur tout et ça aujourd'hui ça
n'a pas de prix donc là on continue avec
deux produits on va avoir d'un côté un
réfrigérateur c'est le ces 555 cd et on
a une machine à laver double machine
elle avec un écran serait retoqué assez
dingue c'est là c'est 16 donc on regarde
ça de près mais vous savez on
s'intéresse à parce que vous avez une
offre complète pour la maison et les
produits qu'on peut venir piloter alors
sont pas encore sorti en france
peut-être sortir aussi on n'est pas sûr
en tout cas c'est en deçà des produits
qu'on pourrait et qu'on pourra piloter
directement avec votre application tcl
omv le truc qui est marrant des gens au
niveau du réfrigérateur c'est regarder
la voyait s'est éteint il ya rien et on
voit rien il n'y a pas d'information et
lorsque vous vous approchez eh bien il
vient vous voit il vous reconnaît un
free se retrouve un petit message vous
avez la température peut venir modifier
directement des choses ça donc ça c'est
très très cool et en fait c'est un combi
multiports telle idée du combi multi
porte c'est quoi c'est qu'en fait
lorsque vous ouvrez un espace et bien
vous n'allez pas gâcher de la
température dans notre espace donc vous
avez un espace principal qui va faire
office de réfrigérateurs ok très bien le
deuxième qui est juste à côté c'est un
freezer donc là vous mettez lé glass
company essayer ça sur le bataclan vient
en tintin on a des espaces flexibles
d'un côté comme de l'autre c'est à dire
que là vous pouvez choisir la
température pour il ya par exemple ça ça
va être du freezer ici également hélas
du réfrigérateur ou alors un versement
ou tout au réfrigérateur au tout entre
isr en fonction des besoins que vous
allez avoir un instant t on a ici 550
litres un revêtement en verre trempé
pratique à nettoyer un petit coup de
trique hop on nettoie ses participants
et tranquille à la maison et surtout
unique et pratique le fait d'avoir ses
différents compartiments et bien ça et
vite devenir mélanger les odeurs et
d'avoir de faire un truc qui va sentir
un peu le fromage alors que de l'autre
côté vous avez des légumes moyer des
fois c'est des choses qu'on n'aime pas
si vous avez le bon vieux monde ce père
qui a bien chauffé qu'on voit la patate
au niveau de l'odeur et de l'autre côté
vous et des petites tomates toute
fraîche est délicate on n'aime pas ça là
vous pouvez venir module est directement
donc ça c'est cool pour l'instant il est
dispo uniquement chimiste pourrait qu'il
arrive en france parce que je trouve
marrant ici c'est vraiment la station de
capteurs parce que lorsque vous partez
et bien l'affichage va s'enlever vous
vous rapprochez vous avez la formation
ça c'est chouette regardez maintenant ce
qui se passait à côté de la machine à
laver donc là vous a en tout cas c'est
intéressant avec double charge double
parti et surtout là vous avait un écran
on la regarde et j'appuie hop là il
vient s'allumer et ça c'est vachement
intéressant parce que si vous regardez
bien vous allez avoir effectivement et
bien le temps pour venir nettoyer vous
avez tous vos programmes et vous
choisissez soit sur le haut soit sur le
bas si je vais sur le haut savoir un
petit peu moins de programmes fatalement
que si je veux aller sur le bas parce
qu'en fait sur le bas je vais également
avoir une fonction sèche-linge qui va
être extrêmement pratique donc en
fonction de ce dont je vais avoir besoin
à l'instant t et bien je peux venir
choisir programme adapté aux ici je peux
mettre six kilos en bachelot m 10 kg le
truc qui est intéressant c'est que pour
une famille par exemple vous allez levez
les affaires du petit ou voulait faire
du blanc et vous voulez faire de la
couleur en bas pour y devenir alterné
directement et on choisit vraiment comme
on veut et autres trucs qui est
vachement pratique c'est qu'à une
gestion complètement automatique et
intelligente des noces à dire que vous
mettez ici et bien votre lessive là le
détergent oui la quantité maximale vous
mettez ici l'adoucissant quantité
maximale et lui il vous dira lens caen
n'a plus donc l'avenir d'oser
directement parce qu'il va venir peser
le loge dans un compartiment où dans
l'autre il à venir adapter la lessive et
l'adoucissant en fonction de votre
programme en fonction du linge qui à
l'intérieur donc une fois de plus la
technologie vient au secours de la
maison pour venir faire des économies
conomie d'énergie parce qu'on va mettre
le programme adapté économie de lessive
économie d'adoucissant on va pas venir
faire n'importe quoi dans tout ça assez
malin alors après ça me ferait un très
grand meuble alors là il est un peu
surélevé mais il est quand même
vachement rome et sousse a bien alors
c'est un produit qui pour l'instant a
été lancée en chine et pourrait
potentiellement arriver en europe n'est
pas si ça pourrait voter mais en tout
cas ce genre d'innovation avec un écran
comme ça ton sac annonce un génial
d'avoir un très bel écran couleur ici
directement c'est beaucoup plus chouette
on a envie d'aller beaucoup plus loin et
à côté beaucoup plus fine et très
didactique là on se parle de pièce
intelligente là on se parle de pièces de
vie intelligente c'est ce qu'ils
appellent le smart living room au fait
vous allez pouvoir venir piloter vos
différents appareils à travers votre
application sur votre smartphone à
travers votre téléviseur ou tout
simplement en parlant un google
assistant travers de n'importe quel
appareil connecté chez vous bien
évidemment au travers d'une application
sur smartphone je pouvais revenir
incontrôlée mot purificateurs d'air mon
robot aspirateur mais également ma télé
sur un ou plusieurs appareils de la
famille donc ça c'est plutôt cool mais
également directement depuis mon
téléviseur voyez ici je vais avoir par
exemple mon contrôle de la maison home
control avec ma petite clim portative et
mon robot aspirateur qui pour l'instant
est tranquillement en train de se
charger donc je vais avoir une maison
connectée beaucoup plus intelligente
quel que soit le nombre d'appareils
quelles que soient les appareils que je
vais venir connecter tout va pouvoir
mears piloter a directement donc ça
c'est vachement bien et là c'est pareil
dans une piègent d'autres façons de
fonctionner il appelle ça le smart
bedroom c'est en gros une chambre un peu
intelligente qu'est ce que ça raconte qu
est ce qui va se passer et bien tout
simplement vous pouvez venir créer des
programmes par exemple vous allez vous
coucher ça vous appuyez je vais me
coucher vous allez avoir la clim qui va
se mettre à une certaine température
l'aspirateur robot qui ne va plus bouger
du tout bref honnir automatiser
certaines scènes de la même manière vous
vous levez hop on va moduler la clim on
va dire pourquoi pas au robot aspirateur
de partie on va lancer le purificateur
d'air il ya beaucoup de possibilités et
je trouve ça assez malin et très
intelligent parce que vous venez
connectée la maison avec tous les
appareils intelligents de tcl il ya des
pots et créer plusieurs scènes j'arrive
à la maison je pars de la maison je vais
me coucher et ça mais pour toutes les
pièces la chambre la cuisine la pièce de
vie la buanderie dont vous avez plein de
choix et je trouve ça super malin vous
voyez qu'on a vraiment un écosystème des
produits si j'étais c'est elle que ce
soit du téléviseur il ya même de la
barre de son il ya des moniteurs faisait
pas tout montré une vidéo n'aurait pas
ces films et vous voyez un peu
l'ensemble pour la maison télé pour
venir se détendre vous avez le robot
aspirateur vous avez la climatisation
vous avez le purificateur d'air vous
avez le réfrigérateur vous avez la
machinerie bref vous avez un ensemble
d'écosystèmes qui est cohérent était
super intéressant pour chez vous avec
pour l'ensemble des produits et produits
sont super qualité et très joyeux je
sais pas vous ce que vous en pensez ce
que vous avez déjà un pro du tcl vous
savez souvent on rentre dans un
écosystème de marc parent production un
téléviseur ou chaude ça peut être un
téléviseur à l'occasion de la coupe du
monde parce que quand même des
ambassadeurs de renom peut-être ça
pourrait être ça peut-être autre chose
dites moi si vous avez des produits tcl
à la maison si vous pourriez en avoir et
surtout quel produit vous ferez de live
vous allez présenter un paquet et fiona
qui vous botte plus qu'un autre vous
marquez tout ça bien évidemment juste en
bas en commentaire et puis nous on
continue à parler tech par les tcl il ya
plein de choses plein d'innovations et
on se fait plaisir et moi je continue à
me balader à l'ifa parce que y'a plein
de trucs très chouette et on est très
bien d'un jeu d'ordan ses soldats les
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt chaos
[Musique]